Hi! I'm Aya and I'm from New York.
And I was born and raised there, so I look Japanese but inside I'm American.
So, I kind of learned Japanese very naturally and English at the same time.
But right now, I'm learning French.
And I feel the best way to learn French is to watch a lot of movies in French,...
...but subtitles in Japanese or English.
That way, when you hear audio, you can comprehend it by reading.
So, in that sense, it's kind of doing two things at once.
So, I highly recommend that.
Hello everyone, my name is Johan from Sweden.
The way I learned English was naturally by growing up.
I never studied English actually.
But in Sweden, all media, all movies, and all music...
...are imported from English speaking countries, usually America and England.
And we never dub our movies,...
...so if we see a movie or TV show, even a children's program, it's always subtitled.
So, we learned to read Swedish and at the same time, we learned to understand English.
So, that's a very good sum of things.
Please watch movies and listen to music as much as possible.
Hi, my name is Yua and I'm from Singapore.
I started learning Japanese when I was 12, and I grew up learning English.
So to me, the best way to learn a language is actually to learn how to speak.
And so, whenever I have a piece of article like newspaper,...
...I would try reading them out aloud and make it more fluid after reading it a few times.
And I also recommend an online newspaper portal like New York Times...
...where you can actually click onto the word and find out how it sounds like.
So I guess, knowing how to pronounce the word is the best way to learn the languages.